okay i'm going to get through this quite
quickly part 1 length to Brett here's a
helpful thing for you I didn't quite do
it in the first question I'll do it now
and hopefully it'll help you work it out
I'm going to write down the actual ratio
in terms of the words they give me right
so I'm going to say length to bread okay
now once i have that in place all i have
to do is look for the right piece of
information here okay now i think we
already established that width and
breadth are the same thing with and
brett how far across okay so therefore
this guy over here that's a that means
the other number must be the 12 right so
there's your basic ratio in terms of the
numbers they give you but we can
simplify a little bit can't we what
factors should we take out I can take
out for now you're right 4 x 4's what
their file i'll write it out longhand
for you if you like I'll make that 12 /
fall and 8/4 you can do the same thing
to both sides okay and that gives me
three to two it's not two to three
months yeah you see the result ok oh the
next question they say I believe linked
to perimeter ok so again I'm gonna write
that down length to perimeter because
it's the same question length hasn't
changed ok so that's still going to be
12 isn't it but I don't know what the
perimeter is at least not yet ok so
primitives all the way around so because
it's a rectangle that's going to be 12
as well and that's going to be eight as
well so it might even write all those in
I should have to to lots of 12 and two
lots of eight alright 2416 that should
be 40 ok now I'll do the same thing I
did before which was work out how can I
simplify this and it so happens it's the
same number that i can divide to its for
isn't it i'll skip this night as I think
you can divide it you can see what's
going to happen divide this you get 3
divide this by four you get
and there's your answer okay now enough
that rectangles let's look at Part C
what's the very first thing we should do
draw it fantastic okay now it doesn't
matter if it's to scale you just need to
be able to draw some conclusions from it
right so something like this is clearly
not to scale okay but I can make some
conclusions about when you're already
when you're ready okay so on my awful
looking triangle I'm going to put the
information that they have ok so I've
got two angles 70 degrees and 60 degrees
okay then they ask us a question what's
the ratio of hmm the third angle to the
sum of the three angles now before we
write anything or before we calculate
anything you can actually already tell
me what the sum of the three angles is
because they're all in a triangle so
it's always gonna be a hundred eighty it
doesn't matter what numbers these were
that's always going to be 180 okay now
how do i work out that this is 50 yes
yeah I need one yeah good so I'm going
to 70 plus 16 plus yeah i'm gonna call
it X I don't know what it is equals
equals 180 that's the angles of a
triangle yeah okay so they go right so
now I have 50 over here so is there
anything I can take out five I could
take out five but there's a bigger even
easier number i can take our 10 I see
the zero on both of them all right
that's 5 to 18 can I take out anything
else that's it yeah we're done okay